welcome everybody to PI data Carolinas I
have a lot of connections to the PI data
conferences both as my role as a
director of the Python software
foundation but also my everyday job is
working on project Jupiter and it is so
cool for me to see the great things that
people are doing with Jupiter and the
ecosystem first I want to thank the
organizers all of the volunteers I had a
blast yesterday getting to meet people
and the folks i talked to how nice they
were how organized things were and it
really is a credit to the community that
you have here and in many ways it is
like the community that we have in san
diego we have a fairly academic
community but then we also have some
good influx of business and we basically
got a lot of people that care about
sharing their knowledge and making
things better I want to thank the
sponsors and the sponsors are critical
not just in putting off that this
conference and IBM giving us this lovely
venue to use today the sponsors are
somebody that make your community better
over time as an organizer of community
groups just finding space sometimes is a
huge challenge so you know to have
sponsors that are willing to share space
to support your groups is is really
wonderful and I really think we should
give it up for everybody and all the
people that traveled here and all of you
for being here because you are what
makes this conference what it is so I
would say give yourselves all a great
round of applause this is my favorite
date of a
zation I've been using it for well
probably close to 30 years there was a
study that was done about financial data
and how to make it understandable by
people and ironically unhappy face you
know a space and happy face was the best
way to communicate that to people and
hopefully if you're feeling unhappy face
now maybe by the end you'll have the
happy face and not certainly by the end
of the day today I think you will be
inspired and have some things that you
can go back and do um so a little bit
about what we're going to talk about
today I'm going to do a brief
illustrated introduction to mentoring
tell a little story that sort of
connects back to the triangle for me and
shares a lot of how i feel about
mentoring we're going to talk about why
mentoring matters not just on a
qualitative sense but also on a
quantitative sense and what it matters
to you personally and why it can matter
to you as a community member it sounds
really simple to be a mentor and in a
lot of ways it is but a lot of times I
run into people in there like well I
don't know how to mentor and so what
we're going to do is talk about five
things that help people become mentors
in a way that they feel comfortable and
then I had at the end I have a question
so are we still good with video if I'm
down here okay cool so encourage others
to imagine the possible encourage others
to manage the possible imagine the
possible Margaret Daniels Tyler wrote
this and she will come back in this
presentation but it is a powerful quote
to me
someday each of you will fly and some of
you sooner than others right now if I
was the baby bird in the nest I might
say it's impossible there is no way I
can fly gravity I'll be splat on the
bottom of the ground before I fly well
we in the Python community know that if
we look at Lorena Barba's notebook on
aerodynamics and share that with the
baby birds you will find out that yes
you in fact can have lift the
aerodynamics are such that you can fly
and maybe just give it a try so somebody
encouraging you to do something so as a
mentor you have the power to change
somebody's life in some way big or small
now being a mentor transforms you into a
leader into someone who can impact not
just one person but many people and the
baby bird went on with a little
encouragement and a little feeling that
things were possible to have his own
little baby bird flight school so again
encourage others to imagine the possible
so we're going to transition a little
bit to a story and the story begins
today here at hi-data Carolina's doing a
keynote something I never thought that I
would do i did a keynote earlier this
year and in the philippines and it was
really a phenomenal thing to do from the
stamp
of seeing how they used open source and
seeing how Jupiter notebooks were being
used in ways that I hadn't even
anticipated yet so but to really tell
this story we need to kind of take the
wayback machine and go back Oh about mm
39 years I'm 50 I love technology it
totally rocks my world but not for
technology's sake for what it can do for
people and so I'm an eleven-year-old
girl I grew up with privilege I grew up
in the shadow of bell labs for those of
you that have never heard of Bell Labs
think of it as IBM for
telecommunications 30 years ago they had
a really phenomenal research center
making semiconductor stuff doing optics
research fiber optics they also had
really cool mainframes and people very
similar to you that went out into the
local community and taught 11 year olds
how to program on a mainframe and I was
really lucky to be one of those students
at the time and that transitioned me
into the next year I was in a pullout
gifted program which as a
twelve-year-old girl really wasn't you
know you want to fit in you don't want
to seem different you don't want to you
know the social thing going on and I get
into this classroom which I have to
spend about a third of my day every day
with and it was me and three guys and
the teacher said well what would you
like to do we're playing Dungeons and
Dragons don't you want to do this and
I'm thinking no I really don't I want to
go back to my regular class where people
are doing art and photography and things
like that nothing against dungeons and
dry
because I have played it and I think
it's a pretty cool game actually but as
a twelve-year-old I did not and so the
teacher says to me well you have to pick
two things that you're going to study
for the next four months really
intensively and in the corner of the
room in a box was an apple to computer
hadn't been put together yet and I'm
thinking can I try that and she looked
at me and she's like well it's not set
up blah blah I'm like I set it up not
knowing how to set it up or even but hey
I'm gonna try it and then the other
thing I decided to do maybe this is
telling I was a college level psychology
class so I got that right brain left
brain thing going on so this Apple to
was phenomenal you can see by the
graphics that you know the resolution
gaming was still really big back then
Atari had just come out with breakout
and I had ported took me probably three
months but I reported the Atari breakout
game to the Apple too and it was an
exercise in exploration creativity
problem solving because unlike today we
did not have the internet we did not
have tutorials on every subject at our
fingertips in fact documentation for
most computers was fairly sparse um but
it was sort of like you're an explorer
persevering and I loved puzzles so it
was a puzzle to me so I'm growing up
with privilege I wind up graduating high
school in three years and then my story
leads me to a little place down the road
to Durham and I started a
graham at duke in electrical engineering
at the time there was maybe a couple
dozen women in the engineering school of
like 190 or so students so you start
distributing around those couple dozen
across four majors fewer still women but
it was something that totally rocked my
world and I went through Duke and you
know finally made it to be a senior and
the data points told this story I was a
really strong student ID already been
taking graduate level classes in an
electrical engineering I was in the top
10% of the class I had done independent
research at Duke Medical Center on use
of optics and monitoring radiation
exposure for early in the early days
with AIDS patients I had also and this
is the connection I kind of have with
Chris Iran Duke's cable television
station for two years and had Dukes it
was all volunteer run broadcast out into
the hospital 24-7 I won't say that it
was quality programming but it was what
it was but it was did go to the hospital
so it kind of kept it fairly tame and as
a result of that I had Dukes
presidential student leadership
scholarship for two years ah and in my
spare time between studying and running
the TV station I worked with a startup
that was the first startup to make video
yearbooks and you think about it now and
on your phone you could like snap
at whatever video yearbook together back
then it was different you had like the
portable betacam that was probably
weighed 10 pounds or so but all of this
kind of led to like what would be an
expected outcome from the data I'm a
senior I'm gonna interview for PhD
programs in electrical engineering makes
sense right I going to graduate with
honors I'm gonna excel in digital
communications research except for I'm
in the basement of Carnegie Mellon's
engineering building and I'm sitting on
the floor in the middle of a panic
attack and that panic attack I'm hearing
these words in my head broken isolated
stupid failure and again and again and
again so my data and my perception of
the data was broken isolated stupid
failure so how could all these other
folks see me as somebody who is
competent successful somebody that they
might want in their engineering program
while I felt like I was a fraud hey
didn't they see the be I got in
microprocessors the graduate class like
earlier in the year what if I completely
messed something up well okay I was
worried they would find me out as a
fraud but even more worried that they
would accept me and I would be working
down in a basement by myself long hours
with nobody who is a pure of mine now
repeat this in about six other
universities
sitting on the floor having a panic
attack thinking that I was a failure so
despite all the privilege despite all
the efforts that had been done over time
panic and later I found out
post-traumatic stress was a reality in
my life the privilege that seemed so
nice and idyllic as a child perhaps
wasn't really like that underneath and
the mentors that crossed my life had a
huge impact many didn't know but they
did and so we go back to the end of my
senior year and I get a phone call for
Margaret Daniels Tyler remember
encourage people to imagine what's
possible and she is at the time a
director of admissions for MIT Sloan
School of Management and she asked me if
I want to come in because she's going to
be on campus and have a chat with her
and I was like okay but you realize I'm
an electrical engineer and really that's
what I should be doing she's like I know
but you know why don't you come and we
can talk about it okay so I finally
agree she was very persuasive and one of
the first questions she asks me is why
do you want to get a PhD in electrical
engineering and with the uncreated
response that I had well it seemed like
that was the expected thing for me to do
based on the data and the projections
that came out of that data well if you
could craft your own PhD what would you
learn and create you've got all these
varied experiences at Duke
that are a part of you what would rock
your world and I said well it'd be
really cool to take some of the computer
stuff and the networking stuff and make
it so we could share information and
educational resources with people in
different places that might not have
access to it so you know high school
students that maybe were very proficient
in math but their high school didn't
offer calculus give them an opportunity
to have access to that information and
then she asked me well why would you do
that and I said well because education
opens doors and she looked at me and she
said do you realize that at MIT you can
combine your electrical engineering with
management study and actually try and
create that and okay the thing about
Margaret Daniels Tyler at the time she
was the first black woman to be an
admissions director at any like ivy
league level school she had a presence a
confidence that she just exuded and I
just SAT there and I was like I don't
know why I'm not doing this and so I
decided to apply to the salon school at
her encouragement she was there she
coached me through how to write the
application how to present my
achievements because remember deep down
inside I was still that broken isolated
stupid failure so it would be very hard
for me to share that
and what was great is not only did she
do that during the application process
but she stayed around while I was a
student there while I was doing my
Master's research and one day I came to
her nice like I don't know whether to
apply for this scholarship I had half a
merit scholarship but I was self-funding
my tuition so the other there was
another opportunity through digital
equipment corporation who remembers
digital equipment corporation okay they
were a competitor of IBM's way back when
that no longer exists their computer
still exists in some research labs out
there you could still find deck faxes
and and other many computers they were
actually used a lot in scientific
research but but that doesn't really
matter so they were offering digital
equipment was offering to merit
scholarships to women in management at
MIT and at the time I eighteen percent
or 33 of the 181 students at MIT were
women four percent were under the age of
23 I was 21 all of my classmates were
like you don't have a chance you've
never worked you've never you know you
don't have the experience blah blah blah
blah blah well okay filtering it with
the broken isolated stupid failure
filter I was like okay I don't know that
I should apply for this I mean it seems
sort of and she her simple question was
why not what do you have to lose as like
an entire weekend of writing application
for this thing and she's like yeah but
what do you have to potentially gain I
was like well the fact
I could eat and have a winter coat
Boston later that year because I had
enough money to pay rent and groceries
and stuff so it was kind of a motivating
factor and so i went ahead and i applied
and ironically i did get that
scholarship and i owe much of what has
transpired since then to the time that
Margaret spent with me and the
encouragement she gave to me and her
helping me see what was possible so
Margaret went on to leave MIT after
being a Dean of the Graduate School she
went on to be a vice president of the
United Negro College Fund she also ran
the strategic direction for a little two
billion dollar bill and melinda gates
foundation millennial Scholars Program
she was a phenomenal and still is a
phenomenal person but the thing that she
did so well was mentor people that she
felt had a strength of character and
would work hard to get what they wanted
and work for others so why does
mentoring matter in our communities I'm
actually gonna grab some water I think
about that for a second how many of you
have actually been mentored by somebody
at some point in your career or academic
life how many haven't been a mentor okay
so we could have meant more mentors why
would you want to well mentoring matters
because great leaders inspire future
leaders and by you sharing your
knowledge in whatever space it is
whether it's research or
ops and great talk Kyle that's somebody
you'd want to work for if you were a
devops engineer and the impact of
mentoring has an unusual impact on
diversity and inclusion Harvard Business
Review did some studies earlier this
summer and the title was diversity most
programs don't work here's what to do
about it well that's pretty exciting as
we try and figure out how to make our
communities more diverse and more
inclusive mentoring was one of the few
things that did work and worked quite
well like there was a research study
within that that showed that Hispanic
men Asian men black women Hispanic women
and Asian women had between a nine
percent and twenty-four percent increase
in advancement uh pay when they had some
sort of mentorship and those are pretty
powerful numbers and so think of
yourself as that person there may be
mentoring one or two people and those
one or two people go out and mentor one
or two people as well and mentoring
unlike a lot of diversity programs has a
multiplier effect it has the ability to
exponentially change our communities
well okay that's all well and good but
what's in it for me we have people
across all different dynamics in a
spectrum we have somebody who was like
me who had very little self-confidence
to somebody who's very
hockey who knows everything and really
doesn't need to listen to anybody else
well both of those people and everybody
in between need mentoring to some degree
perhaps the cocky I can do it all
student needs to realize that maybe
there's other people on the project that
they would like to work with that maybe
could share and collaborate with them
and really what that gives us is an
inclusive community to solve real-world
problems one of the things that drew me
to Jupiter was the impact that the
notebooks could have on people
collaborating in order to solve
real-world problems as an example folks
in the Philippines tuberculosis is an
issue over there and getting folks that
have acquired tuberculosis to finish a
drug regimen and the drug regimens not
that expensive but it's prohibitive
enough that over the course of time
people drop the regimen because I think
it takes about six months that could be
wrong so the notebooks enabled
government officials economists
biologists statisticians doctors to come
together and have sort of a common
language if you will it reduced some of
the jargon of each individual problem
space because you could visualize some
of the data later on and then at the
same time it gave people a sort of a
ramp up the learning curve about the
other disciplines so that they were able
to get an idea into a process and trial
faster and so
when we look at the problems that are
really facing us in the world most of
those problems are not going to be
solved by one person that was actually
my mom in her later stages of alzheimers
and for anybody who's taken care of an
elderly parent there are lots of things
to maneuver good care good resources
financial payments for things the
humanity of the person that you are
caring for and those problems are not
going to be solved by maybe as much as I
would like as one computer software
developer I'm not going to solve that
problem but if I have a diverse
community with lots of strengths and
different experiences somebody can solve
it some group of people can solve it and
think about the problem spaces that you
work in there are likely ways that you
can better communicate with research
partners with other groups within your
organization and it matters because the
hard problems are the ones that are most
worth solving or at least moving forward
on because it's possible to find a
solution so how do you mentor I tend to
look at mentors as not the big huge
formal like I'm going to have this
person be my mentor for the next five
years as I move up the ranks of
Corporate America that's great and that
does work as well but I in our busy
lives and you know the different roles
that we play researcher developer parent
spouse daughter son a Little League
coach chess
somebody I met yesterday he was teaching
chess to elementary schools it was
really cool and another gentleman had a
daughter that was in an outreach program
to learn violin in Durham which I think
has been pretty successful so how do you
mentor well it bad acronym I'm sorry but
basically be a slacker is the best way
to mentor so what you can do in 5
minutes 10 minutes half an hour an hour
matters matters a lot because i'll say
margaret didn't spend more than an hour
with me at any given point in time so
there's five things in this slacker
acronym the first one is show up because
if you don't show up nothing is going to
happen so that's step one kind of ground
zero so be open to people approaching
you and at a scifi conference a couple
of years ago maybe three now I said well
it's just common courtesy just say hello
to people and I had a whole room of
folks including my college daughter
laughing at me like uh we're developers
we can't do that and I was like okay aim
a little higher you can do this we all
like the same things at least when it
comes to code the next thing is to
listen you won't know what a person
needs unless you listen to them I'm not
going to tell you that I don't have
enough money for a winter coat in Boston
if you haven't set the stage and
listened to me before you won't know
that I need help on installing Jupiter
hub on my cluster in my supercomputer
center
if you're not listening to me and along
with that is asking questions and not
the kind of questions that sort of
sometimes show how much we know but
asking the questions like that are more
open-ended what do you think about that
why do you think that would be helpful I
don't really know your problem space as
well as you do are there a few ideas
that you think might work maybe we could
talk about them and then part of being
that slacker is to get off the couch and
actually act on something and the
actions can be small or they can be
larger because let's face it life is
kind of a funny thing it evolves over
time sometimes we have time sometimes we
don't but if you say you're going to do
something try and do it or own up to the
fact that you can't do it and apologize
and say sorry I thought I could but I
can't but perhaps so-and-so could help
you that matters it's it's for building
trust both individually and trust in a
larger space of a community and then the
last part of being a slacker is what
slackers really like which is rest
recharge it is really important to take
care of yourself and it's something that
we don't always do well as developers we
want to stay up all night coating on the
really cool thing we want to contribute
to all these different open source
projects but if we aren't taking care of
ourselves we're liable to get more angry
more short with people unhealthy so it
is worth recharge
you can't be a good mentor unless you
take care of yourself so being a slacker
show up listen question act recharge and
the question I'm going to leave you is
what will you do to encourage others to
imagine the possible thank you